welcome in this session watches redeploy
on application of the utmost importance
and mission-critical value a meme
generator memes are serious business so
we use for our stack called psycho and
kubernetes to guarantee the availability
and scalability of our application just
so you have an idea everything in Google
runs within containers did you know we
deploy around 4 billion containers per
week
it's impressive number to achieve such
scale we needed a reliable - kubernetes
it was developed not to only song
Google's infrastructure challenges but
also to be accessible to developers with
its declarative side of api's kubernetes
can run on Jiki google kubernetes engine
or even on a multi cloud environment
outside of the Google cloud platform all
of that with auto repair auto upgrade
and outer scale called cycle is our
persistent database use to store the
generating memes created by users and it
is set up to have high availability
across different zones but the point is
not the only objective a hand watches we
delete notes and force a failover in the
database after all auto just can happen
and you wouldn't want to miss anything
right how about trying by yourself
the deployment enforce a failover you
can also take this opportunity to have
some fun with memes check out the full
talk to see the deployment steps for
this application in action and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for
more great next rewind content
[Music]